اتفقت اطرافه الاتفاق الايطالي للعمليه
السياسيه في السودان على مهله خمسه ايام
لحل القضايا الخلفيه التي تؤخر التوقيع
على الاتفاق النهائي وقال المتحدث باسم
العمليه السياسيه بالسودان ان الاجتماع
الذي انعقد في القصر الجمهوري بحضور عبد
الفتاح البرهان ومحمد حمدان دقله وبقيه
الاطراف قرر ابل اجماع مضاعفه الجهد
لتجاوز العقبه المتبقيه خلال ايام
المعدوده تمهيدا لتوقيع الاتفاق السياسي
النهائي في السادس من ابريل نيسان الجاري
[موسيقى]
وفي هذه الاثناء اغلق منتسبون للمجلس
الاعلى لنظارات البيجو والعموديات
المستقله بالشرق السودان اغلقوا الطريق
الرابطه بين مدينه بورسودان والعاصمه
الخرطوم عند منطقه سنكات جنوبيه بورسودان
وقال المستشار القانوني للمجلس احمد موسى
عمر ان الاغلاق ياتي رفضا لاتفاق السياسي
لترتيب الحكم في الفتره الانتقاليه وكان
المجلس الاعلى للنظارات البجا والعموديات
المستقله قد اعلنا في وقت سابق قرار اغلاق
الطريق بين الخرطوم وبورسودان ليوم واحد
حيث توجد موانئ البلاد الرئيسيه على البحر
الاحمر بينما رفضت مجموعات السياسيه
واهليه اخرى في شرق السودان هذه الخطوه